what's going on guys this is Rob welcome
back to Comics explained and everybody's
making list videos again time to hop on
the bandwagon so here are the top 10
characters in Marvel Comics that are too
powerful for the MCU meaning if the
Marvel Cinematic Universe were going to
put them into the films they'd have to
reduce their power in order to tell
compelling stories now if you guys want
a more comprehensive discussion on these
various characters and more make sure
you check out our playlist which you'll
find in the description called too
powerful for the MCU perfectly titled
right so kicking things off at number 10
on our list is the void now some of you
guys may not know who the void is and
the void is incredibly powerful people
who do know who the void is are probably
just like damn this is what you're
starting your list off with okay this
list is gonna be nuts when it comes to
the void think of like somebody in
Marvel comics who's basically a little
more powerful than Superman but never
holds back and doesn't care who they
hurt and that's what the void is the
long and short of this is that in Marvel
Comics there's a guy named Robert
Reynolds and Robert Reynolds consumed a
serum which basically wasn't attempt to
recreate the super soldier serum that's
when Steve Rogers into Captain America
he ended up becoming way more powerful
than Captain America and took on the
superhero name the Centric the problem
with this is that Robert Reynolds has
multiple personality disorder or
disassociative identity disorder as a
stone in this day and age and basically
the void is his evil Alter Ego now the
void has done all kinds of crazy things
in Marvel Comics the void has taken on a
full contingent of the X-Men the
Fantastic Four and the Avengers at the
same time and they were powerless to
stop him the Incredible Hulk is afraid
of the Void but it's probably the
greatest display of the void's power it
was actually an alternate reality story
which was basically an alternate telling
of the conclusion of the events of Siege
on Asgard which of course was a story
where basically Asgard was attacked the
void ended up manifesting at the end of
that conflict and basically killed
everybody on Earth all the superheroes
and like Loki and Thor and all the ads
Guardians and then just ascended out
into the universe where it presumably
proceeded to kill Galactus and all the
cosmic entities and basically take over
the entirety of the universe this guy
was pretty broken but coming in at
number nine on our list the try on
Juggernaut so in Marvel Comics and in
his base form Kane Marco is basically
just a guy who took an object called the
Crimson Gem of sidorak which imbued him
with all kinds of crazy enhancements the
most notable of which being whenever the
Juggernaut starts to move nothing can
stop it the only exception to that is
when the Incredible Hulk did it once
even though it was a really really cool
moment it still seemed a little weird
but you've also had 8th day Juggernaut
which is basically when the juggernaut's
powers are enhanced and then Trion which
is the most powerful version of his
character that we've ever seen the idea
behind this is that Juggernaut was
possessed by a spirit called the Trion
and using the power of the Juggernaut
combined with its own insane level of
power Tryon Juggernaut was able to punch
holes in reality literally punching
cracks in the universe this guy is
number nine on our list just to give you
perspective on how powerful the people
on this list are going to become but
moving on to number eight we have
sidorak now sidorak is a ridiculously
powerful character so much so that even
characters like dormammu draw on the
power of sidorak by using things like
the Crimson bands of sidarak he's
basically confined within his own
Dimension called the Crimson Dimension
but if this guy were to ever escape his
reality and enter into the main Marvel
Universe at full power he would be
unstoppable it was even confirmed by
Stephen Strange that nothing in the
universe could stop the power of this
guy the cosmic entities couldn't stop
him Galactus couldn't stop him he would
basically bring about the end of all
things but coming in at number seven our
discussion on Sid Iraq is a little scant
there I will admit but coming in at
number seven is dormammu empowered
Galactus yes there is a point in Marvel
Comics when Galactus is empowered by
dormammu by basically consuming him pray
know how this story unfolds and Galactus
become so powerful so what ended up
happening is that Galactus shows up to a
world to consume it as Galactus normally
does what on this world was a guy named
zolos in an effort to basically save his
world Zola sneaks off to the home of
Stephen Strange steals a bunch of
magical artifacts and then using the
power of those artifacts with Galactus
away from the main Marvel universe
itself and into the mystical Realms this
leads to Mephisto basically going to a
dormammu and saying hey you can control
Galactus and if you have the power of
Galactus well you can basically do
anything and or Mamu always looking to
expand beyond the dark dimension and
conquer the entirety of the universe
meets with Galactus and Galactus
immediately consumes him and basically
absorbs all the magical power of
dormammu so it's effectively Galactus
with dormammu's power there was a point
where Galactus almost escaped into the
entirety of the Multiverse and had that
happened everything would have fallen
before the power of Galactus wielding
the power of dormanu he would have taken
over and conquered and probably even
consumed and destroyed the entirety of
the Multiverse in Marvel Comics now
coming in at number six on our list and
I know people who are familiar with this
character are going to kind of be like
really number six you're putting this
guy ahead of dormammu empowered Galactus
yes and bear with me here there's a
reason why heart of the monster Hulk
also known as like World Waker Hulk 2.0
now a lot of you guys have heard of the
story World War Hulk where the
Incredible Hulk was just more pissed off
than he's ever been heart of the monster
Hulk takes it to the next level and it's
the strongest We've Ever Seen The
Incredible Hulk and the history of
Marvel Comics interestingly enough we
have a video on it here at Comics
explained that you're welcome to check
out once you're done watching this video
but the idea behind heart of the monster
Hulk is that basically Bruce Banner
finds a wishing well and literally
wishes to be able to just fight forever
essentially but the thing behind this is
that this is the strongest the Hulk has
ever been and even Steven strange and
everybody who is observing it came to
the realization there was basically no
stopping this guy the only person with
the power to stop part of the monster
Hulk was heart of the monster Hulk I
mean the guy just looked ridiculously op
in fact Umar who was ruling the dark
dimension at the time actually fled her
own Dimension and went to Steven strange
and asked for help in order to have
Steven strange find some way to defeat
heart of the monster Hulk there was no
way to stop this guy he was basically
breaking the dark dimension imagine
somebody going into the realm of
dormammu or even Umar who depending on
who it is that's writing the story is
sometimes even more powerful than
dormammu and basically overpowering
their realm and even breaking their
realm just based on how powerful they
are none of the magical energy that Umar
had worked that there was no conceivable
way to stop this guy now ultimately they
ended up just draining the gamma
radiation off banner and then he
reverted back into his normal form but
the fact remains it's a ridiculously
powerful version of the Hulk that not
even a being comparable empowered to
dormammu had the ability to stop coming
in at number five on our list and this
is gonna be an interesting situation I'm
here to see how people react to it Hope
Summers and or sink and there's a reason
for this I know a lot of people who are
familiar with these characters are kind
of like what why in the world would you
pick them because of the powers that
they had so when it comes to these two
characters they have the ability to
duplicate the powers of anyone they see
and they can do this for an indefinite
amount of time and there's no defined
upper limit to the power they can
duplicate we haven't necessarily seen
them copy the powers of Galactus but
there's no reason to believe they can't
and if this is something they can do I
know I'm kind of kind of cooking the
books a bit right just let me have my
moment here I really wanted them on the
list but if they had the ability to
duplicate the powers of Galactus or
eternity or Infinity any of the cosmic
entities they would rival them in power
very similar to Protege and in fact we
can include Protege as part of this
group if we want to because he could
basically do the exact same thing and
even using him as kind of a litmus test
to basically establish what Hope Summers
and sync are capable of there was a
point in Marvel Comics when Protege
copied the powers of the Living Tribunal
and the only option The Living Tribunal
had to defeat that guy was to basically
absorb him there was no conceivable way
to overpower him because for every ounce
of magical energy or reality warping or
what have you that the Living Tribunal
used Protege was able to match it and
then counter it and so in this
circumstance there's no reason to
believe that Hope Summers and sync can't
do the same thing but coming in at
number four on our list and anybody who
knows anything about this YouTube
channel knows we had to include this guy
we had to include this guy you had to
know this was coming my man mad Jim
Jaspers now I love I love I love Jim
Jaspers you talk to anybody who's been
watching this channel for any measure of
time and they knew this guy was going to
be on this list Jim Jaspers was on just
a to see this is when we start moving
away from guys who can like do stuff on
a universal scale so guys who can do
things on a multiversal scale so Jim
Jaspers existed in two forms the first
was Earth 2 3 38 and the second was the
main Marvel Universe it involved a story
called Captain Britain which was
basically kind of okay what ended up
happening is that when Captain Britain
was sent to Earth 238 to face off
against Jim Jasper as the reality is he
was never going to defeat him and he
really wasn't supposed to it was
supposed to give him some understanding
of what Jim Jaspers was capable of
because the main Marvel Universe version
imagine Jaspers was more powerful than
the version that was on Earth 238 but
the gym diaspers on Earth 238 basically
created a being called The Fury that
could essentially understand and then
adapt to the powers of anybody that it
went against and it was tasked by Jim
Jaspers with killing all the superheroes
on earth now I know that doesn't really
necessarily seem like an incredible feat
check this out so by a series of
circumstances that are basically just
too complicated to go through in this
video what ended up happening is that
you basically had an attempt to bring
back superheroes on Earth in the earth
238 Universe this led to Jim Jasper's
initiating something called the Jasper's
warp which literally started warping and
distorting the entirety of reality to
the point that his entire universe had
to be destroyed in order to keep it from
impacting and even affecting the rest of
the Multiverse because had the Jasper's
warp gone unchecked it would have
distorted twisted and then eventually
destroyed the whole Multiverse and
Marvel Comics now switch over to Captain
Britain facing off against madgem
Jaspers in the main Marvel Universe
while we didn't really see mad Jim
Jaspers do anything like the Jasper's
warp what we did see was an insane level
of reality warping that was built on top
of the fact that he could have destroyed
the Multiverse there's literally a point
when Captain Britain walks into this
guy's office and he's at an infinite
expanse of space and like Jim Jaspers
starts snapping his fingers and reality
starts shifting around Captain Britain
to the point where he's like a little
kid in school like it's all these crazy
things but the guys hopelessly outmaps
remember like during the events of
infinity war and Avengers end game when
you basically had like the Guardians of
the Galaxy who caught up to Thanos on
the Celestial head nowhere and
everything basically looked like it was
fun but then he used the reality Stone
and then it showed that everything was
like in Flames imagine it happened like
that in the blink of an eye and that's
the power of Jim Jaspers he could just
do it on a whim he doesn't need an
infinity stone to be able to perform
that level of reality warping that's his
power that's how capable he is coming in
at number three the chaos king of Matsu
mikabashi this guy was nuts this dude
was basically kind of a facsimile or a
Harbinger or a Herald if you want to
call it that of the cosmic entity
Oblivion as we said at the beginning of
the video we're not including Cosmic
entities here so because this guy is not
a tried and true Cosmic entity we can
throw him on the list but a Matsu
mikibashi right the chaos King this guy
killed every God across the Multiverse
every single one they all fell the
cosmic entities the whole nine yards and
in fact this guy almost destroyed the
entirety of the Multiverse the only
reason why he wasn't destroyed is
because Hercules was basically empowered
by the Multiverse itself to essentially
defeat the chaos King and so Hercules
basically came out on top but this guy
was capable of eradicating every God and
Cosmic entity across the entirety of the
Multiverse every single one it was cool
to see him do that with just that level
of power but I gotta tell you guys this
dude has nothing on the tattoo
on our list here so coming in at number
two is pre-retcon beyonder and molecule
man now everybody who's familiar with
Comics knew that these guys were going
to be in like the top three at the very
least I imagine you probably suspected
they would be number one number one is a
whole different Beast this guy is just
our number one guy is just god tier so
here's the thing about this in Marvel
Comics you have what are called retcons
retroactive continuity this is basically
when a writer will go in and they will
change the history of a character or
modify them in some way so that their
history is not the same as it had always
been the reason why I say this is
because in Marvel Comics the molecule
man and the beyonder exist in two forms
pre-redcon and post retcon pre-retcon is
when they were their most powerful so
the way this played out is that in
Marvel Comics you've got a universe then
you have the Multiverse which is a
collection of universes and beyond that
you have What's called the Beyond verse
I know it's not a very unique name bear
with me here the whole gist behind this
is that in the Beyond verse you have
what are called beyonders These are
beings of just unfathomable power
astronomical power they're still not as
powerful as the number one guy on our
list but they are incredibly powerful
the idea behind the beyonders though is
that they're basically confined to the
Beyond verse they can't really enter
into the main Marvel Universe but there
was only one exception when this
happened that there was a man on Earth
named Owen Reese who is basically
performing an experiment at a company
called Acme Atomic Corporation what he
ended up doing was inadvertently
creating a Cosmic Cube basically taking
energy from the Beyond verse and then
releasing it into the main Marvel
Universe now where this happens whenever
somebody creates a Cosmic Cube it
usually goes into a containment Cube
which people then use to do all kinds of
crazy things in Marvel Comics because
there was no containment Cube half the
energy went into Owen Reese and the
other half of the energy just flew out
into space and then eventually became
sentient and that's how you get the
original Secret Wars in 1984. the
important thing behind this is that
because Owen Reese was imbued with the
power of the beyonder which we're not
going to go into all the stuff that was
done with this character in Jonathan
Hickman's Avengers New Avengers but
because of the fact that he was imbued
with all the power or at least some of
the power of a beyonder there was
basically nothing that he couldn't do
that this guy had just insane levels of
power and in fact where Owen Reese's
full potential was unlocked and Secret
Wars 1 in 1984 and Secret Wars 2 which
was written shortly after that the full
totality of Owen Reese's power was used
when he went toe-to-toe with the
beyonder who was slightly more powerful
than Owen Reese but the battle between
the two sent shock waves across the
Multiverse and that's the power of These
Guys these guys have the ability to
alter the very fundamental structure of
the Multiverse itself all Cosmic
entities fell before these guys The
Living Tribunal Galactus eternity
Infinity every version of them except
for the Living Tribunal there's only one
Living Tribunal in the whole Multiverse
but every Cosmic entity that existed in
every Universe across the Multiverse
fell before the power of these guys but
even they are not as powerful as our
number one guy also known as Clyde
wincham the Marquee of death so this guy
is a [ __ ] this guy is just an absolute
Hoss so check this out just to give you
guys perspective on how powerful he is
the Clyde wind basically comes from what
we call the real world in Marvel Comics
so if you could read about this world in
which you live right now in Marvel
Comics it would be Earth 1218 I think is
what the numerical designation is the
important thing here is that in his
reality Clyde wincham was the only
person with powers and he had the
ability to alter reality when his father
died he basically resurrected him
subconsciously his mom freaked out hit
him over the head with a Candlestick and
left him being wheelchair bound and in
somewhat of a semi-conscious vegetative
state the only thing this guy cared
about when he was basically being left
in a hospital be taken care of by
various nurses were his comics when
those were taken away this guy reached
into the main Marvel Universe and
summoned every single superhero
including Galactus to his reality just
brought them in and like quite literally
everything was popping off and Galactus
just immediately started to consume
Earth in the real world now eventually
everything sorted out and Clyde wincham
is basically taken to a place by Reed
Richards where he's just kind of put in
this machine well he'll just dream happy
dreams until his body he just shuts down
of old age but there's an alternate
reality where all that stuff happened
the exact same way except basically a
whole bunch of villains one of whom was
the molecule man Owen Reese who we just
talked about that basically showed up to
where it was that Clyde wincham was
being held and then broke him out Clyde
wincham immediately Unleashed a wave of
psychic energy that killed everybody
there he then took off into the time
stream and disappeared for a few billion
years so what ends up happening is he
comes back to the present day and you
find out Clyde wincham is actually the
guy who taught Doctor Doom everything he
knows and is pissed off about the fact
that Dr Doom has always lost to the
Fantastic Fort so when Dr Doom goes to
challenge this guy Dr Doom basically
leads the entirety of Earth's
superheroes against the Marquee of death
which is what Clyde winchend is calling
himself now and literally all the Earth
superheroes ultimately end up killing
the Marquee of death Reed Richards is of
course killed in the process Doctor Doom
marries Susan storm and after about five
years has led to Earth into a Utopia at
which point Susan storm asks are you
satisfied with everything and Doctor
Doom says yes I'm finally content and
then it's revealed none of that happened
that the Marquee of death had altered
reality in such a way to where he
tricked Doctor Doom into believing that
this great big huge battle had taken
place and Dr Doom had single-handedly
saved not just the universe but the
Multiverse because the Marquee of death
was a guy who was powerful enough to
wipe out whole universes with a wave of
his hand and that in reality five years
had not passed it had been five minutes
he ends up turning doctor Doom's heart
to Stone his blood to acid takes him
through a time portal drops him off
three some odd million years into the
past where Doctor Doom gets eaten by a
Megalodon shark now the rest of the
story kind of unfolds his own way but it
turns out the only being across the
entirety of the Multiverse that can
possibly stop Clyde wincham is actually
Clyde winchip so what they end up doing
is going and getting the version of him
himself who originally appeared that was
taken to the machine where he would
dream happy dreams forever until his
body fell apart due to old age and that
version faces off against the Marquee of
death and because this battle had
weakened The Marquis of death in such an
extreme way the newly returned Doctor
Doom kills the Marquee of death don't
ask how Doctor Doom returned it's comic
book logic but with that being said guys
that's our list let me know who you
would have put in the number one spot
thank you all for watching and I will
catch you all later
peace